necrosis is a one form of Celtic which  is often associated with pathological  situation or mechanical damage Hallmarks  of necrosis involves pathology  Association inflammation and unorganized  mode of cell death one Hallmark is  swelling of mitochondria swollen  mitochondria are associated in  perinuclear region and there are several  proteins which get activated in this  process known as cyclophylline D  cathpsin and kalpins all of that are  detrimental for cellular aspect there is  a dissipation of the mitochondrial  proton gradient and alteration of  mitochondrial membrane potential other  features involve lysosomal rupture  calcium overload plasma membrane rupture  ATP depletion and excessive Ross  production  so here is the overview of all the key  features in the necrosis if you want to  know more  subscribe